if if dana if let's just say comes to a
time where dana wants to retire walk
away who does dana's job
that's a tough tough spot to fill um
i'm not sure i think uh
daniel cormier maybe maybe somebody
who's been in combat sports i don't know
if he knows a whole lot about the
business side
but i i think he would be a great face
of a company daniel cormier yeah is is
daniel going to be able to poke and
challenge like uh like uh dana does you
think daniel could do because you know
dana's like
he will steer the pack because he knows
like even the one of the best things i
like to watch is his uh post fight
conferences
so ticket sold out 16 208 pay-per-view
buys boom uh fight of the night is this
questions and then he goes and he says
well i wasn't too impressed i thought
the judge is this
what's sport boxing do you ever see
people talking about the judges sucked
everything's about protect the judges
and the referees he goes straight after
the judges for sure yeah interesting guy
can you see connor ever doing what he
does
honor connor
i don't know if uh
i can't speak on it i guess he could
he i guess he could a personality like
conor cause
conor is you know
he's a great fighter but the guy's a
great smack talker as well yeah
but leading a company i'm not sure if
you'd want that
you know
got it okay
be in the face and the voice of a
company might get out of hand here and
there yeah so you need a diplomatic guy
that's that's yeah yeah maybe a little
bit of that somebody who stands their
ground but doesn't cross the line i
think that's cool and daniel definitely
stands the ground yeah yeah yeah
so if you like this sort of short club
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]